[Music]
look at those words
one year of coving let's think about
that for a second the now
year-long pandemic has taken a major
toll on the mental health
of the medical workers too a new review
of 65 studies from around the world
finds that
one in five health care workers have
experienced depression
anxiety ptsd or a combination of all of
those conditions
the new streaming program 60 minutes
plus shows us one doctor's struggle in
georgia
wesley lowry has her story aaron rayburn
rojas
a critical care doctor at northeast
georgia medical center
says her workload is still more than
double what it was pre-pandemic
with no relief in sight have there been
moments that
have felt like you're reaching a
breaking point or have been difficult or
where you've been overwhelmed
every day every day yeah it's not
uncommon for us to take a minute to go
cry
i mean i cry in my office all the time
everything you do is about getting
people better
and a lot of times it just doesn't
happen
the lack of being able to help someone
in their most vulnerable moments
is the injury the fact that it happens
over and over and over again
is what i think really causes the the
damage
and you've said that you think about
walking away from it sometimes yeah
how seriously do you consider that
depends on the day
as i'm preparing for my shift the night
before
i start to get a physical reaction to
even thinking about going to work
i start to get palpitations
and then i start to think about why am i
doing this i don't have to do this
there's been days where i've had to take
a personal day
just because the thought of coming back
in and doing the same thing again was
just too much
i don't think it substitutes you know
what will be needed
as far as debriefing and therapy after
this
you definitely plan to go to therapy oh
absolutely yeah
wow even the helpers need help 60
minutes plus correspondent wesley lowry
joins us now with more on the story
wesley it's good to see you
you know we just heard that one doctor
say i've often thought about walking
away i know you talked to many health
care workers
was that a common thing with them they
just think
about leaving of course you know
we i'm actually still down in northeast
georgia
where we've been talking to health care
workers in rural hospitals and we also
our team spoke with healthcare workers
across the country and we heard
time and time again you know we've asked
a just a monumental task of our medical
workers this last year
the amount of death they've seen the
pain they've seen the surges
and virtually every health care worker
we talked to said there are times where
they have thought about walking away
because it's just so difficult
but they don't so who is helping them
how are they getting through it
well and that's one of the big questions
and it's one of the big tasks and
challenges ahead of us as we
emerge from this pandemic is how do we
make sure to take care
of these health care workers many of
whom are traumatized
you know like many professions medical
work does have a stigma around it
as it relates to mental health folks who
are scared
to come forward and say i need help and
so there are
some organizations national associations
who are
asking for a kind of sweeping
attempt to chronicle uh the mental
health of health care workers asking for
money to be devoted there was some money
in the covid relief bill
but asking the biden administration
essentially to create a tracking program
like we did for the 911 first responders
making sure that
everyone who was on the front lines of
the pandemic we know where they are we
know what they're going through and we
can provide help for them
in our last piece wesley we had a health
official say we don't have a health care
system
we have a sick care system and what
you're learning or what you're hearing
is that
now it's actually threatening the
stability of what we still call
the health care system how so
well we have to remember that even
before the pandemic we were facing a
relative crisis in nursing
uh that we didn't have an overflow of
health care workers and now
we've asked them to do this herculean
job to respond to a pandemic
and a virus that we didn't really know
how to deal with initially and to do so
without resources without time without
ppe
and so we've taken what was already a
depleted workforce
and then handed them this unthinkable
task
and it's going to be unsurprising if in
the months to come
we see any number of healthcare workers
walking away further depleting the
system
making it harder for us to get care we
got to go wesley but i do want to know
what the workers told
you about the vaccine
they they're met all the workers we
talked to her most of them have been
vaccinated
they really really want folks to get
vaccinated
because what they worry about is the
summer holidays the spring holidays
happen they're worried that if people
aren't vaccinated they're gonna have
another search
right you don't have to tell me twice
thank you very much wesley good to see
you
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources
you can call the national alliance on
mental illness the helpline at
1-800-950-6264
or in a crisis you can text nami that's
n-a-m-i
to 741-741 and wesley's full report is
on 60 minutes plus this sunday on the
new viacom cbs streaming service
paramount plus